warning the following video contains
made the spoils and Code Geass r2 and
may contain an opinion which differs
from your own if you have not seen our
to cannot stand bad language or you're
just an annoying fan boy [ __ ] your
discretion is advised
but that guy you are you
ah you know what I really wasn't looking
forward to this review pilot because I
never had to plan to review this in the
first place if not for about half my
subscribers simultaneous outing hurry up
review RT you know bed Polly because
there is a lot of good I can say about
the show that I haven't already said I
mean will the superficial things are
basically identical so let's get all the
repeated praise out the way shall we
the soundtrack still the same epic
Suffolk boys was animation is still just
as good if not better and wasn't season
1 and character designs are still so
pretty that the commit builds its art of
like a dog saggy bollocks cross weed Amy
Winehouse's face or just a tea Winehouse
voice acting is still great with
maintaining a brilliant job with Lelouch
it's Martin Prime and all characters
still come complete with chin so pointed
out you probably attached them to Paris
Hilton's vibrator and use them to drill
to the centre of the earth
okay so now we've all that praise out
the way you may think I'm being overly
harsh in the rest of this video but
that's mostly because I just don't want
to be repeating myself my first review
as you all probably know by now I
thought the first season of Code Geass
is one of the best the most entertaining
animes I've seen and I think that review
gave everyone the impression that I'd
just be rolling out the ten in the
artery of you so I feel like it's my
responsibility to fly in and tell
everyone why this isn't the perfect
anime now before you want to die this
video none subscribe to me let me know
that I certainly didn't think RT was bad
the first eight or so says we're just as
entertaining to me as a hold of the
first season was and has one of the best
most epic anime endings I've seen period
seriously the setting is in my personal
top three best anime endings of all time
that's saying something but I'm sure you
already knew all that anyway and knowing
that about half my subscribers the fans
of the show I know that I just can't
blindly ripping this anime like I
usually do so allow me to try something
different this one time like two tried
to make some constructive points and why
I think art is far inferior to this
first season point one the mecha battles
ok my first point maybe my weakest point
since this is more of a personal
preference but a thing I liked most
about the first season were the tactics
and strategies using the battles not the
actual makers fighting themselves
sunrise it seems took this concept and
flush it down the toilet
gun with the clever tactics that were
decisive factors and victories and I
said we would get professor ADHD here
who had installed some ultra boost to
mega gun types supersonic powerful armed
thingy that would instantly [ __ ] all
enemy forces within a matter of minutes
and what can only be described as Gundam
disorder oh sure they tried to pull the
wool over eyes when making it seem like
tactics were involved but let me ask you
this did a matter that shrink a
outsmarted Lelouch in China when he had
a nightmare which he seemingly pulled
out of his ass that destroyed all enemy
nightmares in a single bloody shot
did any tactics matter in in Turkey
about a winin en Callen appears out
nowhere wipes out everyone fact that the
enemy conveniently leaving the keys
right next to the Guren for her to use
exactly point to character consistency
there are many complex characters in
Code Geass and all the character
development in season 1 of summize he
planned out but in season 2 characters
seem to change at the top of a hat with
people doing a complete 180 on their
ideals and natures and changing
themselves for the convenience of the
plot were other than a natural
convincing reason let's take the
relationship between the Lucian Rolo for
example apart from his gear she's
nothing to me I'll use you up and then
throw you away like a piece of trash my
funeral offering to surely will be rolos
life he will atone for what he did to
her you think you could ever replace
Nunnally in my heart you're in a posture
I hate you I love you I despise you I've
been trying to kill you but I just keep
missing the chance I said get out
no some using your deals like that do
you wanna say just what I'd expect of my
little brother that's right I thought so
cuz I know who you really are
it's morphin time your big brother it's
just a liar thank you wrong this big
change of heart happens in about ten
minutes and this type of a complete
transformation seems to be scattered
everywhere in the series like we all
know Suzaku is a goodie two-shoe he
never strays away from his ideals and
will always try to change the system
from the inside and where was a Huey set
and any ends gained through contemptible
means aren't worth anything
results gained through contemptible
means are worthless yeah that's the one
so we all know he would never do
anything - no I've been naive up till
now no Neal stubbornly maintaining that
the means are more important than the
end result what matters are results
brilliant and I could go on all day
about suckers instant lines with a luge
at the end of the series
I mean sure Lelouch maybe have tried to
kill me on several occasions made the
early woman I've ever loved slaughter
hundreds of my own people and then shoot
her in cold blood but [ __ ] that [ __ ]
would be FS right so let's all go sing
Kumbaya and dance in the [ __ ] meadow
point three plot twists anyone who's
seen Code Geass know that he has hard-on
for plot twist and tries to end every
episode in one and while in season one
every episode left me wanting more the
twisting season see were a bit more hit
and miss with some keeping me on the
edge of my seat while the others being
dissed oddly [ __ ] it was all nice
and dandy for the first few episodes but
after this scene I started to worry a
bit
this is outrageous
zero has appeared but not as expected
that is so this was your plan despite
our overwhelming firepower you figured a
way to move a million people time to get
exiled everybody we're all zero so we're
all out of here that's right on zero
let's get deported zero cool come on I'm
Spartacus I'm smarter and things only
got worse when they tried to explain the
Geass aspect of the show with the whole
sword of Akasha business and then the
whole Charles and Maria night he trying
to protect Lelouch by sending him to
Japan business which has sunny plot
holes you can fly jumping [ __ ] Jets
through them and then there's a whole
illusion controlling God business and I
really could go on in the end the
problem I had with the plot twist is
that the series seemed to have this
because I told you so attitude about it
Marianne spontaneously developed a Geass
power when she was done because I told
you so Charles and Marianne would
actually trying to protect lives because
I told you so
Luce is actually a gay sexually
frustrated vampire robot from the future
because I told you so okay that I isn't
actually true but you get my point point
for this [ __ ] point five seriously am I
the only one who hates me either this
much I mean Shinji curry could dropkick
a kitten into an orphans face and she
would still be a more hated fictional
character than him Sakura ash take from
you yo the entire cast of inuyasha and
kanye west's ego well I could go and
describe from the usual force everyone
else has ie the excessive fanservice the
filler episode and the cameraman being
completely incapable pointing anywhere
part of Matt Collins asked whenever she
is on-screen but if these were my only
grouts for the show that I probably
would have minded as much overall the
show just felt rushed which was
disappointing because the first season
felt so well planned out you can see how
the writers wanted to end it since has a
bloody brilliant ending but they
obviously didn't plan the means to get
there which resulted in inconsistent
character development and some
borderline [ __ ] plot twists don't
get me wrong despite everything I said I
didn't hate the season I'm just
disappointed because I really wanted to
like it because of this I had a hard
time deciding what score to give or to
since there were some truly five-star
moments in the beginning and ending
while the middle was just a big letdown
but let's hope this announcement of a
new Code Geass project will make me
forget about all my frustrations in the
season and okay wait a minute what the
[ __ ] is this I give this anime a 7 out
of 10
getting all your hair